[Musique]
tu te rappelles notre rencontre bas
mesdames et messieurs les jurés vous
avez été témoin de l'atrocité et de la
cruauté des crimes abominables de
l'accusé vous avez vu des blessures
horribles des crânes défoncés des
mâchoire cassée
[Musique]
l'accusé se lève pendant des années je
me suis dit que c'était ma faute et je
me suis approché tout ce qui m'était
arrivé si je ne l'avais pas fait une
confiance aveugle promet - tu me
quittera jamais lisse et notre fille a
disparu c'est sain ted
est-ce que c'est toi qui as fait ça non
[Applaudissements]
de schutter cheikh m de fond ce sera le
premier procès télévisé de l'histoire
des états unis
cet élégant mon dieu je me suis déguisé
en avocat aujourd'hui
bien certaines choses que vous ignorez
vous n'avez jamais vu ça même dans vos
pires cauchemars
c'est des conneries il s'agit là d'un
procès pour meurtre vous marcher sur des
oeufs
vous risquez de laisser des plumes
cette affaire est la preuve que
l'assassin est un monstre je voudrais
pouvoir tout commence
comment tu m'aimes pas je suis pote de
toi dégage ces assassinats ont été une
extrême sauvagerie
férocité ignoble monstrueux est-ce que
c'est toi qui a fait ça ted
ça va bientôt prendre fin ce sera fini
quand tu auras dit la vérité
[Musique]